les crépitements des photographes
journalistes et nerfs des plus sérieux
le premier ministre britannique pourtant
heureuse d'annoncer la conclusion d'un
texte de 2000 pages les accords
commerciaux post break site
enfin finalisé il sera lui absent
je suis très heureux de vous annoncer
cet après midi que nous avons conclu le
plus gros accord commercial à ce jour
d'une valeur de 660 milliards de livres
sterling par an un accord de libre
échange global entre le royaume uni et
l'union européenne
semblable à celui ci avec le canada que
les disputes avec nos amis et
partenaires européens et étaient parfois
intenses je pense que c'est une bonne
affaire pour toute l'europe et pour nos
amis et partenaires également une fin de
période de transition qui se conclut
avec beaucoup de soulagement et
d'amertume
du côté de bruxelles le royaume uni a
choisi de quitter l'union européenne et
le marché unique de renoncer au droit
aux avantages d'un état membre
les négociations ont été très difficiles
c'était un accord pour lequel il fallait
se battre il faudra des fondations
solides d'un nouveau départ avec un ami
de longue date
londres et bruxelles ce qui donc bons
amis mais avec certaines règles des plus
strictes à respecter pour les
entreprises d'outre-manche
à partir du 1er janvier une seule norme
pour ces dernières se montrer juste dans
le domaine de l'environnement du droit
du travail ou encore de la fiscalité
pour éviter sanctions disciplinaires et
l'apparition de droits de douane
différents aspects du contrat qui
satisfait les dirigeants européens je
suis très confiante dans le fait que
nous avons ici un bon résultat avec cet
accord nous jetons les bases d'un
nouveau chapitre dans nos relations
le royaume uni continuera d'être un
partenaire important pour l'allemagne et
pour l'union européenne en dehors de
l'union européenne l'unité et la fermeté
européenne au payer l'accord avec le
royaume uni est essentiel pour protéger
nos citoyens nos pêcheurs nos
producteurs
nous nous assurerons que c'est bien le
cas l'europe avance et peut regarder
vers l'avenir unis
souveraine est forte le président
français tient à rassurer les pêcheurs
tricolore grands perdants de cet accord
pour la première fois depuis 1973 le
royaume uni reprendra bien le contrôle
de ces eaux d'ici juin 2026 les pêcheurs
européens renom seront ainsi à 25% de
leurs prises prises qui s'élèvent chaque
année à 650 millions d'euros
l'union européenne a promis de s'engager
économiquement auprès de ces pêcheurs
pendant cette période d'adaptation
il va y avoir une baisse des volumes de
pêche c'est pour cela qu'il faut
absolument mettre en place un plan
d'accompagnement si on veut maintenir
l'existence même de nos pêcheurs et
garantir l'avenir de la filière et ses
emplois qui font aussi notre identité
pour quel est son agglomération pour
l'ensemble de notre façade littorale
je salue cet accord dont l'importance
est fondamental sur le plan économique
comment se traduira donc la diminution
annoncée des droits de pêche dans les
eaux territoriales anglaise sûr qu'elle
stocke sur quels volumes dans quelle
zone de pêche
quelle instance pour en assurer le
contrôle et sur quelle durée
malgré des promesses non tenues dans ces
négociations l'opposition britannique a
assuré qu'elle voterait dans les
prochains jours cet accord pose préc
site
à noter que l'ecosse europhile a appelé
hier de nouveau un référendum
d'indépendance pour jeu si tracer son
propre avenir